je vais réaliser le fantasme de milliers
de téléspectateurs et notamment de joey
starr et de michel cymes je vais vous
ligoté les volontés
est-ce que vous acceptez ce challenge
pour vous oui à d'être sûr pour vous je
suis prêt à tout rejoignez-moi sur la
scène gilbert
un poil de graisse c'est parfait
magnifique noeud papillon merci avec les
compliments de la maison un peu ému là
pourquoi c'est pas vous allez me ma
tâche et ligoté absolument aux douces un
peu tendu mais oui j'ai jamais été du
côté de ma vie donc il ya un kit est pas
ici tout est bienveillant on va essayer
d'apporter un peu de mal jusqu'à ma
confiance en vous assurant seront
n'oubliez pas que c'est vous qui faites
le tour c'est moi qui fais le tour
évidemment j'avais oublié alors ici se
trouve une corde extrêmement solide et
je vais vous attacher la main de cette
manière regarde je suis gaucher un
gaucher comme barack obama allait
génisson away avec les mains droites
sont dégainés on est d'accord
bon vous placez de cette manière et je
vais vous attacher la deuxième main va
bien chez nous tout va bien va mieux
dalton bell a fermé un peu eh bien c est
un travail de dur labeur et je fais
trois ne rien pour vous gilles verdez à
bastia et marseille alors dire est haché
au lédat est très facile à présent
trouve abaissée à la vitesse supérieure
supérieur ici voile et je récupère la
coop et je vous la place où tout a non
mais les bayonnais le tweet est ce qu'on
fait un remake du second degré
franchement ce serait pas mal
la première ça fait un peu où la
wallonie pour la bouche nadal et
m'étrangler la non vous inquiétez pas
les vomir ménages j'avais déjà vomi avec
mes yeux la france y est là on l'a peu
de les marquer encore ce soir non oui
comment de cette manière ce tour et tout
public je deviens le précieux marre de
la villardière est très content et c'est
faux et je place
évidemment la corde
de la meilleure façon suis tout excité
actif le pervers label bbe rt revers
mais rien que ça où placer sa voix dire
un poulet rôti la wii est il pas encore
grillé 1
alors là je réalise le fantasme de
tellement de france ça ouais s'imaginer
par imagi rafah tous à la place à la la
la vous êtes plutôt osé faire ça et
kelly plus tôt ah oui je lui ai proposé
qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant vous
allez vous donner
alors là j'arrive sur votre arrière on
ne voyait rien de faux serré le tout
dure glaxo niel hop suresnes fait rater
gentil chat va serrer plus frais de
service
ok tournez vous vers moi bon il ya rien
de tendancieux avoue être très bizarre
là mais avec son jouet ouais c'est vrai
bien les jambes faire les jambes wallace
et je vais taupe t il je suis pas
revenir bon c'est pas grave parce que
vous êtes suffisamment armé oui c'est
sûr mais là dessus très bien bon nous
avons agi l'adresse à regarder moi je te
convertis au niveau du ventre et vous
étouffez vraiment alors à présent je
vais avoir besoin de quelqu'un dans le
public quelqu'un qui porte une veste pas
papa attendait lever la main qui
accueille veste de costard comme moi b à
messieurs bonjour à votre nom mehdi à
même de bruit pour mehdi
[Applaudissements]
bobby voilà dix prenait le micro et on
vous a mis des lego retrouver et grands
en fait parce qu autant que vous elles
sauront vous aviez dit que en venant sur
ce plateau assister tranquillement à une
émission de télévision ou pourriez
peut-être participé à un tour à ce que
vous êtes prêts à remplir le challenge
de gilles verdez ça me pose aucun souci
aucun souci pour ça aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on a cela vous allez
rentrer tous les deux dans la cabine à
lézignan dans la can alors c'est un tour
absolument tout public pour entrer à
l'intérieur où placer intérieur a laissé
vous aussi les deux fermes et les deux
séries de excusez moi je mets vrai oui
c'est du togo de fermer ses bureaux via
hérité connaît le métier les villages
avez-vous 38 ans et quel est votre
métier comptable comptable d'accord ça
va compter les sous pour une banque jean
a entre autres si vous êtes l'une est
ici c'est parce que vous êtes fan de
magie oui c'est ça d'accord à votre plus
grand magicien à part moi évidemment à
part vous way
mon père était un grand magicien oui
comment s'appelle-t-il man ou non mais
en fait ça à chaque noël en fait ils
oublié sa spécialité comme toi allez on
sort médias sa piscine est ce qui se
passe
j'ai le vernet attaché ici les niveaux
regarder vers le passé à travers ici
tournez vous vous êtes toujours attaché
oui que l'on voit avant après l'échec
d'un incroyable à genève est déjà
incroyable comment as tu te relèves de
vinyle et j'en ai aucune idée en fait
j'étais en train de parler avec vous je
me suis orient avait un partenaire
extraordinaire
ah oui j'ai flux magique à des joutes
lieder jusqu'ici a failli étouffer
vraiment là voilà alors si vous verrez
voulait récupérer votre veste monsieur
l'abbé s'il vous plaît oui très bien eux
c'est combien 50 balles 5 handball à la
porte écoutez vous libérer merci vous
pouvez dire
gilles gilles on vous laisse duty free
et j'avoue que de gilles verdez et
d'écossé il a un super